sabemos el último vídeo que si tenemos
una concentración de iones de calcio
alta a dentro de la célula muscular
esos iones de calcio se enlazarán con
las proteínas de troponina las cuales
cambiarán su forma de tal manera que la
tropo miosina se quitara del camino y
después las cabezas de miosina pueden
caminar a lo largo de los filamentos de
actina y luego vamos de hecho a tener
contracciones musculares a una alta
concentración de iones de calcio
tenemos una contracción a una
concentración de iones de calcio baja
estas proteínas de troponina vuelven a
su conformación estándar y halal o
podrías decir que ponen a la tropa
miosina de regreso en el camino de las
cabezas de miosina y entonces no
tendremos una contracción aquí tenemos
una
track
muscular y a una concentración baja de
calcio
podrías decirle
de la
acción relajación la siguiente pregunta
sería cómo regula el músculo si tenemos
una contracción de concentración de
calcio alta o una baja concentración en
la relajación o incluso una mejor
pregunta sería como hace eso el sistema
nervioso como el sistema nervioso le
dice al músculo que se contraiga que
haga su concentración de calcio alta
para que se contraiga o hacer la baja
nuevamente y se relaje y para entender
eso recordemos un poco de lo que
aprendimos en los vídeos de neuronas
déjame dibujar la unión de terminales de
un axón justo aquí en lugar de tener
sinapsis con una dendrita de otra
neurona tendrá sinapsis con una célula
muscular
esta es una sinapsis con una célula
aquí la haré de esta manera y verás lo
que es esto en un segundo
esta es una sinapsis con una célula
muscular déjame etiquetar todo solo para
que no nos confundamos
este es el axón más bien él
con
mal
de la acción está es la
un poco de terminología de los vídeos de
neuronas este pequeño espacio es la
hendidura sináptica esta es la neurona
pre sináptica esta es la célula
postsináptica en este caso no es una
neurona y aquí tenemos a nuestra
membrana una
para nada
lula
lar
y haré probablemente en el siguiente
vídeo o quizá en un vídeo posterior te
mostraré la anatomía de una célula
muscular en este vídeo será un poco
abstracto porque quiero que entiendas
como la concentración de cationes de
calcio es regulada esta es la membrana
de la célula muscular también llamada
sara coleman
lee más
esta es la membrana de la célula
muscular y aquí puedes observar una
caída hacia dentro de la célula muscular
si viera la superficie de la célula
muscular se vería como un agujero o un
espacio que va hacia adentro de la
célula pero aquí estamos viendo un área
transversal imagina la doblándose hacia
adentro parece como si la hubieras
moldeado con una aguja o algo parecido
obtendrías un doblez en la membrana y
esto de aquí el llamado túbulo t
tu bulo
t
es bueno empezar a utilizar nuestra
terminología y la t solo se usa debido a
transverso es transverso a la superficie
de la membrana y lo realmente importante
en este vídeo es que tienes este
orgánulo en la célula muscular llamado
retículo zarco plástico es el rey título
co
de hecho es muy similar a un retículo
endoplásmico en su estructura pero aquí
su función principal es almacenar el
retículo endoplásmico está involucrado
en el desarrollo de proteínas mientras
que este es principalmente un organelos
que almacena lo que hace el retículo
zarco plástico es que tiene bombas de
iones de calcio en su membrana tiene
bombas de iones de calcio en su membrana
y lo que éstas hacen es ser pasas lo que
significa que utilizan atp para darle
combustible a la bomba
tienes atp
entrando el atp se une a él y quizá un
guión de calcio se unirá a él dibujaré
millón de calcio en rosa quizá un guión
de calcio se unirá a él y cuando el atp
se hidroliza en a t
p más un grupo fosfato eso cambia la
conformación de esta proteína y bombea a
lyon de calcio hacia adentro los iones
de calcio son bombeados al interior
el efecto neto de todas estas bombas de
iones de calcio de la membrana del
retículo shark o plástico es que en un
músculo en reposo tenemos una
concentración muy alta de iones de
calcio en el interior una concentración
muy alta de iones de calcio en el
interior y creo que probablemente
podrías adivinar a dónde va esto cuando
el músculo necesita contraerse estos
iones de calcio son expulsados en el
citoplasma de la célula y luego pueden
enlazarse a la troponina
y hacer todo lo que mencionamos en el
vídeo anterior lo que nos importa es
cómo sabe cuándo expulsar los iones de
calcio al resto de la célula este es el
interior de la célula interior
de la
la
muscular y entonces esta área contiene
los filamentos de actina en las cabezas
de miosina y todo el resto la troponina
la tropo muñoz y na
todas están expuestas a este ambiente
puedo dibujarlo aquí para hacerlo más
claro tenemos nuestros filamentos de
actina justo ahí lo estoy dibujando de
una manera muy abstracta veremos más de
la estructura en un vídeo futuro quizás
tienes tu cabeza de miosina justo ahí y
luego tienes a tu tropo miosina
enrollada alrededor y se mantiene en su
lugar por la
tropo niña
por las proteínas de troponina justo así
este es un dibujo muy abstracto pero
creo que esto te puede dar una idea de
lo que está sucediendo digamos que esta
neurona y llamemos a esta una neurona
motora
neu
todo
está mandando la señal para una
contracción muscular pero primero que
nada sabemos cómo las señales viajan a
través de las neuronas esencialmente a
través de los axones con el potencial de
acción
podrías tener un canal de sodio aquí
tiene su canal regulado por voltaje así
que podrías tener un voltaje positivo
ahí que le diga a este canal de sodio
regulado por voltaje que se abra pero
cuando se abre permite que más sodio
fluya al interior esto hace un poco más
positiva a esta zona y entonces eso
activa el siguiente canal regulado por
voltaje para que se abra y sigue
viajando hacia abajo de la membrana de
la acción y eventualmente cuando obtenga
su nombre al suficientemente positivo
los canales regulados por voltaje del
calcio se abrirán todo esto es un repaso
iones de calcio esto es un repaso de lo
que aprendimos en el vídeo de la neurona
eventualmente cuando se vuelva lo
suficientemente positivo para estos
canales de calcio regulados por voltaje
permiten que los iones de calcio
ingresen los iones de calcio fluyen al
interior y se unen a esas proteínas
especiales cerca de la membrana
sináptica o de la membrana pre sináptica
de ahí
estos son iones de calcio se enlazan a
proteínas que atracan vesículas y
recuerda que las vesículas eran solo
estas membranas alrededor de los
neurotransmisores todas éstas contienen
neurotransmisores
cuando el calcio se enlaza a esas
proteínas permite que ocurra la ex oz y
ptosis permite a la membrana de las
vesículas unirse con la membrana de la
neurona y el contenido es expulsado
hacia afuera todo esto es repaso de los
vídeos de neuronas esto se explica con
muchos más detalles en estos vídeos pero
tienes a todos estos neurotransmisores
expulsados y estamos hablando de la
sinapsis entre una neurona y la célula
muscular el neurotransmisor aquí es hace
útil
na
pero tal como lo que pasaría en una
dendrita la acetilcolina se une a los
receptores en el shark o lema o en la
membrana de la célula muscular y eso
abre los canales de sodio en la célula
muscular la célula muscular también
tiene una diferencia de potencial a
través de su membrana tal como lo hace
una neurona y eso permite cuando este
amigo obtiene un poco de acetilcolina
permite al sodio fluir al interior de la
célula muscular
tienes una carga positiva ahí y eso
causa un potencial de acción en la
célula muscular luego tienes un poco de
carga positiva si es lo suficientemente
elevada para el nivel del umbral
activará este canal regulado por voltaje
de aquí que permitirá que más sodio
fluya al interior
entonces esta zona se vuelve un poco
positiva y por supuesto también usa
potasio para revertirlo es igual que
como funciona dentro de la neurona
eventualmente este potencial de acción
tienes un canal de sodio aquí se vuelve
un poco positivo cuando se vuelve lo
suficientemente positivos se abre y
permite que incluso más sodio entre y
luego este potencial de acción tendrás
un canal de sodio por aquí desciende por
este túbulo t así que la información de
la neurona imagina que el potencial de
acción se transforma en una especie de
señal química que activa otro potencial
de acción que desciende por el túbulo t
y esta es la parte interesante de hecho
esta es un área de investigación ahora
te puedo dar unas fuentes si quieres
leer más acerca de esta investigación
tienes un complejo de proteínas que
esencialmente conecta al retículo zarco
plástico al túbulo t
y sólo lo dibujaré como una caja grande
aquí tienes este complejo de proteínas
aquí la gente cree que incluye a las
proteínas
ah
na
y na
pues
nada
y
de alguna manera están involucradas en
un complejo de proteínas aquí el cual
hace un puente entre el tubo lote y el
retículo zarco plástico pero lo
relevante es lo que sucede cuando este
potencial de acción viaja por aquí
cuando aquí se vuelve lo suficientemente
positivo este complejo de proteínas
activa la liberación de calcio se cree
que la rai anodina aquí es la parte que
libera el calcio pero podríamos decir
que quizás se activa aquí cuando el
potencial de acción viaja aquí abajo
cuando el potencial de acción viaja lo
suficientemente lejos este ambiente se
vuelve un poco positivo con todos los
iones de sodio fluyendo al interior esta
caja misteriosa y puedes buscar en la
web estas proteínas para intentar
entender exactamente cómo funciona esta
caja misteriosa activa la apertura para
que todos estos iones de calcio escapen
del retículo zarco plástico
y luego todos estos iones de calcio son
expulsados al exterior el retículo zarco
plástico
a solo el interior de la célula al
citoplasma de la célula
ahora cuando eso pasa que podría suceder
bueno una alta concentración de calcio
los iones de calcio se unen a la
troponina tal cual como lo dijimos en el
inicio del vídeo el guión de calcio se
une a la troponina
quitad el camino a la tropa miosina y
luego a la miosina utilizando atp como
aprendimos hace dos vídeos empieza a
caminar a lo largo de la actina y al
mismo tiempo una vez que la señal
desaparece esto de aquí se apaga y luego
estas bombas de iones de calcio
reducirán la concentración de iones de
calcio otra vez y luego la contracción
parará y el músculo empezará a relajarse
el punto aquí es que tenemos este
contenedor de iones de calcio que cuando
el músculo está relajado está
esencialmente sacando a estos iones del
interior de la célula así que el músculo
está relajado no puedes tener a tu
miosina subiendo por la actina pero
luego cuando obtiene la señal los vuelve
a soltar y tenemos una contracción
muscular nuevamente porque la troppo
miosina se quita del camino por la
troponina eso es fascinante
y sobre todo que esta sección no haya
sido comprendida aun si quisieras
convertirte en un investigador en
biología este podría ser un tema
interesante para estudiar es interesante
simplemente estudiarlo de un punto de
vista científico entender como esto
funciona realmente pero quizá hay
enfermedades potenciales o subproductos
de proteínas disfuncionales en este
complejo tal vez puedas hacer que éstas
funcionen mejor
quien sabe hay impactos positivos que
podrías tener si de hecho descubres
exactamente lo que sucede aquí cuando el
potencial de acción abre los canales de
calcio ahora tenemos la idea principal
sabemos como una neurona motora puede
estimular la contracción de una célula
permitiendo al retículo zarco plástico
soltar o permitir a los iones de calcio
pasar a través de esta membrana hacia el
citoplasma de una célula y estaba
leyendo un poco para este vídeo y estas
bombas son muy eficientes una vez que la
señal desaparece y esta puerta de aquí
se cierra este retículo zarco plástico
puede regresar la concentración de iones
en aproximadamente
milisegundos esa es la razón por la cual
somos tan buenos en parar contracciones
puedo dar un golpe y luego regresar mi
brazo y tenerlo relajado en una fracción
de segundo y eso es porque podemos parar
la contracción en 30 milisegundos que es
menos que un 30 de segundo te veo en el
siguiente vídeo donde estudiaremos la
anatomía de una célula muscular de una
manera más detallada